we've done a whole bunch of topics
throughout the year already I've done a
lot of different topics and each one of
them is kind of like the mathematics all
understanding a certain sphere of
reality understanding all the patterns
of relationships that some years ago so
I want to see if you could remember
these because we've done algebraic
geometry LED see we introduced algebra
to help us understand the patterns or
relationships between particular kinds
of things
what did algebra let us work with does
anyone remember hand up yeah Frank okay
algebra helped us work with numbers but
not just 18 ohm is I mean in some sense
it's not the minutes older that has an
opposite it is a particular kind of
number that algebra helps us work with -
okay well you should use decide you're
pretty rules the chief remember premium
rules are a bit like pronouns you know
what for nails are like yes
hey she etc it's a would you put in
place of you know a proper now right in
place are you substitute it so what's a
pro do bro what is a pretty yeah very
good precisely in fact I just repeat
that it's a letter that Soviets that
stands in the place of another number
and the reason we do that the reason we
have X's and Y's and A's and B's is
because we don't know what those numbers
are we can still work with them so if
you want to finish off this sentence
right algebra and mathematics of unknown
numbers numbers you don't know they're
valuable but you can still work with
them which is great okay let's keep
going
see you could hit the pan geometry is it
a bad I don't know cuz usually geometry
is about patterns or relationships
between what kinds of objects this is an
easier one actually 3d 3gl machines the
mathematics of 3z okay i think of it a
more general way it's shaped right and
those shapes could be
or 3d we haven't looked at 4d or 5d yet
you could okay so other is the
mathematics of unknown numbers or
numbers you don't know do you ever trace
the mathematics of shapes as figures
now what's probability the mathematics
home I've got three words for you that I
love very much and they're very much
part of your everyday experience okay
probabilities the mathematics all
suggest Christians okay [ __ ] actually is
my first word what are the chances okay
chance is a good word so what have you
done Joe yes bets okay when you're not
sure about whether something's gonna
happen
it might work might not you know the
chance that you can bet on it okay now
this idea of Betty and chances let's do
to my last two words which is if you
don't know something can happen this is
really about uncertainty right now
that's kind of weird because in
mathematics we love to have these that
are certain it's like look here's a
pretty rule tell me what its value is
you could tell me what it is with
certainty but the whole point of
probability is that in life is certain
something should I don't know if it's
gonna be this or that I want the
opposite of uncertain when you're not
gonna stop wailing okay you can see the
same confidence because here's the thing
right this morning I woke up and I was
like okay what should I wear to work
today
what yeah I don't have that many choices
right now should I should I wear lots of
different layers should I wear you know
a really thick shirt a thin one
I could have confidence that I could
wear something they'll be reasonably
suited to the weather because I looked
up the probability of today's right and
it said okay the forecast is supposed to
be 27 degrees roughly that's on the warm
side okay so therefore I use this idea
of probability to be confident
what's gonna happen during the death
shits on sent to confident language
allows us to describe things and it
allows us to describe them with accuracy
so we can work with them okay so I've
got actually one two three four and a
fifth phrase word I'm going to give to
you so let's talk about this in the
realm in the sphere of probability and
we talked about the experiment we don't
just mean like it's science what the
experiment is experiment is just simply
when you actually carry out I've got
actually the words here right when you
carry out a situation that involves
chance right carry out a situation so
for example that might be taking a dime
and rolling it that would be an
experiment okay it's a situation that
involves [ __ ] okay well let's give it a
go now an event or an outcome is what
results after an experiment so if we
want to stay with this idea this
experiment of rolling a die right what
might be a possible event or possible
outcome that could have what event has
occurred here
it's a - right you'd call that a - there
are lots of other things that are
possible you can roll a 2 or a 4 or 5
hours etc okay
all of these are called events or
outcomes
now lots of experiments the the main
kind way can be interesting are what we
call random okay
some random experiment is where all of
the events are outcomes all events or
outcomes
if they're all equally likely to happen
as you hurt if you're using a die right
and it's a fair die then all events and
alcoves have an equal chance they're
equally likely okay so we know what an
experiment is that's what happens when
you do something basically an event your
outcome is what happens at the end of
the experiment random experiments are
where all those better outcomes are the
same chance one last phrase I want to
give you and it's thought we're going to
focus on in this lesson it's a weird
phrase which is why I've left it to the
end is what we're going to look at the
phrase is if you can't quite see it
sample space sample space sample space
means what are all the different events
or outcomes that could possibly happen
in this experiment let me repeat that no
like for you what are all the possible
events or outcomes in any given
experiment okay so this is all possible
events here that experiment
okay so most of the time is pretty easy
to identify what each of these features
are for example call you back to our
dime what is the sample space of rolling
a die okay well we already listed out
like some of the events or outcomes that
could happen but if I want all of them
what I did yet to kill okay now just
write that for me underneath your die
okay so one two three four five six
that's the sample space for rolling a
die right that's the sample space for
all the good night